Android patterns for performance
Sometimes, the cause of trouble is not obvious obvious performance problems,
But a small trivial cost
For small functions that are run repeatedly
Which accumulate to become big problems.
I'm Joanna Smith.
Instead of allowing small things to develop into critical problems,
You can configure payments to keep your app running.
Almost everything in computing is accompanied by pressure in performance.
This may include something great, such as removing image compression,
Requiring a set of memory allocations
To store the argument data.
Or, it may be simple, such as copying additional memory
And manage the index associated with recurring jobs.
These performance pressures are not usually a major concern,
But when executed several times
I mean a great repetition,
These pressures can become a huge burden on your application.
Batch configuration is a useful procedure.
Batch configuration is the process of grouping occurrences of a task.
Thus the pressure occurs once and not once for each repetition.
For example, if you show the same image twenty times,
Try uploading them once before you start
Instead of uploading them for each offer.
Compiling your accounts together gives greater value.
For Android,
One of the most important areas of using batch configuration is with network requests.
There are costs for each time you need to turn on the cellular connection of your phone.
Therefore, if you send the package once every 30 seconds,
You pay that cost with each package.
Instead, you should compile accurate requests for two minutes together,
Then turn on the wireless connection once and send all the requests
At the same time.
But the composition of payments is very useful in other cases as well,
Such as custom views.
Instead of computing a conversion matrix for each element,
You can group them
Make small changes to the larger conversion matrix,
Saving your precious resources.
Then the clearest case is to use batch configuration
It happens when you need a job
To computerize a search table before working on the data.
Here, a batch copy is a collection of 20 bits of data
To create a single search table
Is a clear gain from batch configuration.
It indicates the great importance of batch formation
That all modern processors
Now come equipped with sporty support for batch formation.
Single-order functions allow you to access multiple data
Perform the same sports functions
On multiple pieces of data at the same time.
So instead of consuming CPU cycles
On each of the four parts of the data, you can consume one cycle
And get the same results.
This is the essence of the performance really.
Discover every opportunity to minimize everything even the slightest pressure performance.
Because the 16 millisecond pressures occur in one frame
Is all it takes to destroy your frame rate.
To see other improvements and more performance tips,
Check out the rest of Android Performance Patterns,
Think about joining the G + forum for tips, guidance, and help.
But more importantly, keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.